And maybe I just don't I don't trust
Hutch implicitly the way that you do.
Well, it's like what if what if the
evidence is false? What if you're being
used as a puppet? Does that concern you
at all, Hutch?
>> I wish there was a way to punish him
like legally more harshly for that
because I think that is deplorable
behavior that is does deserve
punishment.
>> It's not that he just is using somebody.
It's that he pretends he is somebody. He
pretends he's a certain guy with certain
morals and he's not even not even close.
You please just explain the situation.
Okay, so there is a clipping Discord
that I'm a part of. Okay, I will ask for
links to stuff. Uh I will suggest clips
to people. I'll retweet other people's
clips. Right? Basically, they're trying
to post like cut up logs with absent any
context as if this is like an evil
doxing server. Destiny wants this to go
and float into his greater narrative
that I'm running like a cabal that's
been working against him that hates him
and wants to undermine everything he's
ever done. So, but he did this. He said,
"Got to say I'm not terribly surprised
to have found this in the leaked snark
Discord logs. Folks, this is online
politics. If you're invoking dead family
members over this stuff, you're years
overdue for extensive therapy. Delete
your accounts and re-evaluate." So, they
cut off whoever the this was. Now, if
someone like that was doing something
like that, I think that there would
probably be a level of value in at least
putting the screen name there. You want
the people that own the server to be
able to go, "No, we saw that and we
banned them." But this isn't what I do.
I've never been like this.
>> I have I think I got sent a a time stamp
of Connor and Doobie arguing about the
Snark server.
>> Oh, really?
>> I think a lot of people see what's
happening. Yeah, I I try even the um
commentary are like latching on like you
Tommy C and they're latching on to this
stuff. I think they even know really
that it's they're like they just you
know they know it's an easy attack right
now. Yeah, I think basically a lot of
>> you got like you know SCP morons that
are on the the edge of that that you
know will sit there and pretend to be to
>> what I was just saying with Connor with
regards to Connor specifically for me I
feel like he sees what's going on and
he's just like not willing to just go
yeah I'll never talk to these people
he's like whatever he's going to have
the assoc associations he's going to
have he kind of just expects Destiny to
tolerate it the same way
>> he expects us expects us to tolerate his
association with Destiny
How long is this doobie thing? I kind of
I kind of want to switch over. I'm
sorry, guys.
>> Uh, literally so far I mean I checked
the thread that ogre boy has and both
statements are incredibly neutral.
>> Like that's not you guys spamming live
and learn is it someone was spamming
Hutch killed his uh killed his sister
over and over. That's even moreed up.
You can correct me if I'm wrong. I've
watched this content twice now. But I
feel like they said no no no no. We know
that the brigade was in the server and
we have evidence that there was no
action taken.
>> Yeah, that's what that's what Hutch's uh
narrative is. And it's just an extra
>> and and again
>> and so so that's why you're not going to
find this big argument between Orgo and
somebody else where he's calling them
out for doing this because they they
weren't doing it or at least they didn't
say they were doing it. You know, nobody
in the server was saying they did this.
>> I called Hutch a liar over this. You
could easily just blow me out and post
the logs.
In fact, I I um I tried cuz like I said,
I wasn't in the server for months, ever
since I got this new account.
>> Um so I tried yesterday to go and find
it to see if it was true before I made
any comments about it. Um unfortunately,
I think I think it's probably because it
got leaked. I think they archived um the
uh the like anything before the 11th of
of May, right? From before whatever got
leaked. It's not deleted. I I think they
they still have it. Um, but you know,
it's just not public anymore for me to
look it up.
>> So, will you will you walk this back
though? Let let's say that I mean I'll
I'll walk it back or I'll say that this
is an evidentiary gap where let's say
that they finally release the manifesto
and they spam all the or they show all
the evidence of what they believe to be
nefarious behavior in the server and
they omit evidence of people harassing
Hutch via Lib and Learn. Like there's
just no evidence whatsoever that this
came from
>> Well, well, I was just going to say I
would
>> there's no reason for them to like by
the way in terms of Destiny saying he's
got to release his manifesto to release
those logs. That doesn't follow at all
that he can't that he's wait for his
court case to release the manifesto and
that he has to wait for the manifesto to
release the logs. It just none of it
follows. It doesn't make any sense. No,
it's obviously just about
him wanting to have a vindication
narrative to
>> try and move on from his court case
with.
>> Well, and I think what I think he's
hoping is he doesn't have a vindication
narrative, so he's hoping that he can
drum up enough like outrage or anger
that he'll get like more things leaked
to him or that he'll like eventually
discover something. I think he's just
like delaying as long as he can to try
to find anything.
>> Oh yeah, that that's true. Sure. But
yeah, but what what that you know that
whatever they have it will be used for
that.
>> Yeah.
>> You know.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> And walk back my
>> but let's say the opposite is true.
Let's say that you just haven't seen
>> the evidence that some people server
>> like I I wasn't like like obsessively
following the server or anything. And
from my my perception it was just a
clipping server where people would come
in talk. I think I had like an argument
about Israel on there once. Uh and most
of the is just you know there are um
streamers of these people who are like
generally like on the left side I think
of politics. Um it's the impression I
get they follow these streamers. Hassan
um uh [__] uh Pisco Hutch um uh
[__] uh who's this other dude?
There's like a whole like channel
dedicated just like clips from different
streamers that they follow, right? And
people post their own streams in there
too. Um so not unusual. I think your
server has a channel for posting clips
and when there's an argument.
>> Well, Missy, it's like realistically
I think at this point Connor and a bunch
of other people should say, "No, no, no.
You have no evidence that these people
have doxed or done anything like that.
You're just a total liar, right?" Like
for Destiny has been saying this for
over a year now and has gone after
people's tried to dox people over this.
Like it's crazy how long he's just had
this like Schroinger's cat, Schroinger's
Doxer thing here where he's saying, "I
have proof of this." But he won't show
it to anybody the whole time
>> happening on stream. Um and and your
community thinks it's funny or the other
guy's stupid. They'll post a stream
like, "Oh, look, this argument is
happening." And they go into chat and
they talk stupid this guy is. Like
that's totally normal for a Discord
server. Like it's not that's not
harassment. I think that's totally
normal. Um, so I guess I I need to be
like clear about what they think is
harassment. Because if harassment is
just, hey, there was a stream happening.
People thought I was stupid. Someone
posted that stream in a server where
people thought I was stupid and those
people came and called me stupid. Again,
normal behavior for every Twitch stream
ever.
>> Sure.
>> I think I think where I think where
people are going to argue that it jumps
the shark though is going to be the
personal identifiable information in gay
ops, right?
>> Yeah. And I just doxing happening. if it
did happen. I wasn't aware of it and I
didn't see anything there that would
indicate they're okay with toxin. So I
just didn't see it
>> well in the sorry I was just pulling up
my my drawing or whatever the so but but
then we
>> which of course we need to make this
course this will sort this conversation
out in a in an instant.
>> I just pull this my diagram real quick.
Let's uh do we can sort the diagram
consult the graph. So, for instance,
like I will not make the claim that
seeing Well, hold on. Number one, that
Caiba emailing Rose and her family is
indicative of anybody else's actions
besides Caiba.
Um, I'm not I'm not going to make that
claim. And then, same thing, I should
have never let this like narrative take
hold. I should have argued this like
extremely extremely strenuously at the
time. It was actually such a mistake to
let anybody like I basically was good
faith and was like, "Okay, like you
good. I can see why you think this is."
It's like, "No, nope. Nope. He acted at
a higher moral standard with a higher
moral character than anybody else
involved here. You like you guys should
have been arguing it the whole time. I
feel like it's uh it was a huge mistake
and we will not be making that mistake
again
>> with the Who's that? I'm I'm Robert
Baratheon. Moody Moody Morgan. Robert
Baratheon. uh the cy
like he obviously is the only person who
had any concern for anyone who acted in
like any sort of like moral way
whatsoever. Now maybe you could argue
you shouldn't do that and I said I made
a rule against him like I just can't
have people reaching out cuz it's it's
like um going to eventually go
disastrously right but
>> it's bad precedent and also he did take
it too far. It's just,
you know, this whole idea that you can,
if you're someone online, you can never
contact someone relevant to a case that
you know information about.
>> I I don't understand this thinking.
Connor was expressing this thinking
earlier in his stream when I watched
this earlier.
>> It's they justify it because they would
feel bad if they didn't like do
something to prevent harm. So, they're
like, "Well, it has to be wrong for me
to ever reach out or care that much."
That's that's how I see it for a lot of
people.
It's because you could just evaluate
case by case in my opinion
>> because um yeah I I think honestly like
you know if you're going to do that sort
of stuff just
do it on your own time. Don't brag about
it online. Don't go into Discord talking
about it. Just like do the right thing
and move on. You know don't get obsessed
with it.
>> Yep.
>> It sounds It sounds like Cy a little bit
obsessible.
>> I think he basically was like worried
this person was going to disappear and
he reached out one time too many. Well,
I say one time like one time to a couple
different members of their family, I
think.
>> And like that's too far.
>> But again, everything before that like
they always they're like he sent 30
emails to her. It's like
>> yeah, letting her know like hey here's
this platform you should take down.
Here's like this thing people are like
trying to look you up on, right? In a
way that she was reciprocating talking
back on.
>> Yeah.
uh Shimu and Neandros openly talking
about using PII tools in order to look
up information on TechOne's potential
alt/mod,
they're making the argument, well, we're
properly ma motivated and we're trying
to expose a crime. But then often times
when we get into talking about Saiba or
any of that kind of stuff, we kind of
get the commentary from people that's
like, okay, well, Destiny's a bad guy,
so he kind of deserves it. And and so
that's where I'm saying like
>> oh what
by the way getting her like basically
looking her up to get like her testimony
for the Destiny case that's like totally
morally neutral. There's nothing bad
about that. And Saaba whether or not
Syboa is involved I still think that
happens. So I just I think that's like a
goofy thing to talk about Desty's case
with regards to this. It's whether or
not her him contacting her is bad. And I
think the way he did originally was
definitely not bad. It feels like there
I know that you you are an individual
>> deserves
sorry I'm not saying like deserves like
like deserves what specifically
>> well that's why that's why I would ask
individuals so I would ask Jtock and
Queen and I would ask you what does
Destiny deserve does he deserve to have
his
>> and I'll remind you guys that we're live
on a platform that has a deal and so we
cannot answer
>> something similar similar On a on a real
though, it is just like, you know,
foolish pun flest punishment allowable
under the law. He should be he should be
held accountable. That's what should
happen.
>> Yep.
>> You should
>> Yeah. No one's saying you should be
swatted or any stupid like that, right?
I mean, unlike he's saying
>> it's like I could hate somebody and
think they deserve worse than they
should get for punishment and still be
like, "Well, but I have to follow the
law and be a normal human being cuz if I
don't then gives everybody else license
to do the same thing, right?"
like morally what he deserves is
probably some civil penalty and in my
opinion
I think some some kind of criminal
penalty but I wouldn't say you know
>> my opinion is not within the law so we
we just continue
>> spammed on Twitter does he deserve to be
sued into the ground does he deserve to
be incarcerated uh what what does he
deserve
>> I mean I personally I think that uh this
technicality about the the um the date
that this law was made active
uh where the revenge thing I think it's
a little bit I wish there there was a
way to legally punish him um much more
harshly for sharing revenge or if you
don't want to call it revenge sharing uh
news and sex without consent um I wish
there was a way to punish him like
legally more harshly for that cuz I
think that is deplorable behavior that
is does deserve punishment um I think he
should be punished u for doxing people
for weaponizing weaponizing his
community to dox people and harass
people I think those are bad things um I
don't think he deserves deserves to be
doxed and swatted and I don't think his
deser his kid deserves to be with or his
family uh deserves to be like harassed
or whatever. Um but yeah, it's just I
what I would say he deserves is just uh
if we can't if he can't like um be
legally punished for sharing news with
indoxing people and uh encouraging like
violence against people, which he's done
repeatedly against like uh like Queen
and whatnot, uh then he just deserves
the same criticism any any YouTuber
streamer gets. You know, people making
video basically turn him into a local,
right? Uh because he's a he's acting
like a crazy person. like that's normal
for YouTube streams, you know, not not a
big deal. But I I want to say something.
So, you're waiting for this manifesto
that I'm sure will be released. And my
pers my prediction is that he's going to
selectively release things to uh try to
fabricate a narrative just like Hutch
did. Um or he's going to make comments
without any evidence just like Hutch
did. Um he's going to lie about the
timeline just like he did a little bit
ago that I just showed you. Um but I
don't I don't think you need to wait for
it. So Hutch made these claims. Hutch
claimed he had the screenshots to prove
what would happened in the server
regarding his dead sister. So just tell
him tell him to post the screenshots
publicly and post all the names of the
people that were doing it and post but
Hutch won't because he was probably told
not to which is just like hey you're
going to make an allegation publicly and
somebody tells you but don't post the
evidence right now. Well it's like what
if what if the evidence is false? What
if you're being used as a puppet? Does
that concern you at all? Hutch.
>> I don't I don't think it does. the son
of the geek
>> post what Ogre boy said like we know the
timeline now is uh January 26 at 7:51
p.m. Ogre boy time. So tell them to post
those screenshots specifically to show
what everything that was being said
around that cuz OG boy is claiming that
nobody in the in the server did it. They
didn't say they were doing it. Um I
think when JO talked about it, he said
that there was like comments about Hush
being like a a bald who couldn't follow
the conversation or something like
around that. Like that's what they were
talking about
watching the stream. Yeah. Totally
normal. Um but none of them were with a
sister. None of them said they did it.
So there was no argument about that.
That that is something that I'm gonna
hold you to.
>> That is something that I'm gonna hold
you to though where I'm gonna, you know,
in a month or two if they do have that
evidence, I'm going to be like, "Hey,
Doobie, how do you feel now that we have
updated evidence that there actually was
people in the server who were
participating in the
>> snarking of his dead sister?"
>> Yeah, I would say it's wrong to do. It's
[__] up behavior. Again, I can't sign
on to everything that was ever said in
any Discord server that I'm in, right?
Like, so I'm your server. I'm sure
people say [__] in there that I disagree
with all the time. uh you know I'm in my
server I I know people say crazy [__]
there all the time so like yeah it's I
can't
>> the argument is going to be though it is
going to be guilt by association um so
the if you so so for instance like you
and I both dealt with the stochastic
rhetoric wars of 2019 to 2022 where
effectively the community that you
attract the community that you police
and by the way you know Destiny actually
used to be super aggressive about this
uh where he would say, "No, no, no, no.
As a creator, um if you are permissive
of misogynist behavior or racist
behavior in a non-joking way or if
you're permissive of XYZ ABC behavior."
>> Oh, he's got a whole hive of What the
are you talking about, Connor? Like,
shut up. Shut the [__] up, man.
>> I think he's saying Destiny used to be
big on this, but not anymore.
>> Destiny was never big on this. Destiny
may be figned being big on this for like
6 months during the Red Pill arc. Off on
that one, too.
>> I know cuz guess what? I used to be in
that chat making misogynist comments all
the time. All right. I I literally could
say for sure absolutely not.
>> Then, you know, you're going to
cultivate that kind of community. And I
feel like that's just descriptively
true. So, one of the things that they're
going to fall back on argumentatively,
and I'll just give you a preview of the
fact that I'm going to agree with it, is
the fact that if you have a server where
people are using docs tools openly, no
criticism, uh if, and I'm saying if
because I haven't seen this evidence,
right? But if there's a server where
they're doing they're boosting tweets,
they're boosting tweets specifically
that are meant to with other creators.
Uh which I have seen evidence for then
and I J
>> wait meant to with other creators like
does he mean clips from our streams?
Like I
>> I clips from their streams. I don't
think it matters either way. But the you
know what what is with if it's you know
if it's not a lie if it's not malicious
then what what's the argument there
>> is a genuine criticism
>> has admitted to and then if we see
evidence and this hasn't been
established but let's say that we see
evidence that there were two or three
people who were in the server and
they're like yeah lol it was me I was
with Hutch you know his dead sister who
gives a [__] let's I think said uh let
let's turn Hutch's sister into a chair
or something like as a joke, right? Then
yeah, I didn't say whoa whoa. That's not
my joke. Hello.
>> I definitely I heard Queen say that on
the stream like two days ago.
>> TV reviews chair at my hutch sister
desk. I think you said something like
that.
>> I I did say I I Well, I did I did repeat
what said, but that's not my joke, is
it? Let's not give me credit.
>> Reviews brother chair. Yeah, brother
chair. Brother chair. My bad. Consists
of logs of me being misogynist.
>> Sure, that's legal. Like I'm I'm not
going to sue you, but at the same time
I'm going to view that as like wildly
antisocialed up behavior and I'm going
to associate correlated negative
antisocial behavior. The best example
and listen, I don't necessarily have
like a war to fight with forethought or
anything anymore. Okay. But like all you
need to know about Destiny's like real
long-term connect commitment to fighting
misogyny in DGG was basically when forth
when he was confronted on forethought
telling Kelly Jean that she was going to
end up having to a dog for her only fans
cuz she was like
>> an unlovable loser that Destiny was like
you know what Kelly Gene exception I I
I'm not even going to try to not even
try to police this Kelly Gene exception
with your community because of the
stochcasticness of it. Now, if you want
to say DGG does the same [__] I'm going
to be like, "Yeah, there's schizophrenic
elements of DGG that do do the same and
it's up and they shouldn't be doing it
and Destiny shouldn't be encouraging
it."
>> Sure. But, so one, uh, again, I don't
know every single thing about said in
that server. When I looked at it, um,
which wasn't often, it was just clips,
people talking,
people arguing about things, uh, people
hanging out in chat, watching streams or
watching like movies or whatever or
playing video games. Not not this was
not like a if if I think like organized,
uh, channel or server dedicated to with
somebody. I think uh, what Dan Sultman
had in Destiny server dedicated to with
Assan for like months. It's like a
channel specifically dedicated to this
where they were like they had like
templates for emails he could spam to
his advertisers and they were trying to
find his family members openly, right?
Like that was that was existed in the
server for months. That's what I think
when I say oh this is a community
dedicated to harassing somebody or with
somebody. That is not what this is. This
is just
>> can I engage in the same which uh
>> so so just real quick do you remember
Twitch poll uh that
>> that's obviously true. I want to hear
Connor's rebuttal of this
>> which discord server that was around
like forever ago. Uh, I mean, was it the
one I only knew about your server. I
only knew about the politics server. I
didn't know about a specific Twitch pull
server.
>> It was a very small server that was made
forever ago with like Samantha Savage
and uh,
>> yeah, Samantha Banana. She's she's one
of my favorite skits, too.
>> Yeah, she's cool. Um, and it was just
like a bunch of streamers on the server
and like small streamers and they would
post clips and their community would
come and post different clips and post
their streams and they would talk about
it and if there's a stream happening
they would post it there so people would
go and and watch the stream and argue
about it like that. That's what kind of
what this is and I understand it's uh
primarily organized around people they
dislike. Um, so if uh
I h
it's got like a hater spirit to it, but
like I I do think there's some positive
elements to it as well. Like like
there's community. There's there's like
an actual drive and a direction. People
like the political messaging in a lot of
cases. It's it's not all hate. I would
say there's a hater element for sure.
possibly possibly a majority hater
element, but it's not like it's like 99%
hate. I would not say that.
>> Uh Hutch says something stupid. Very
likely there's gonna be a clip of it in
there and people are going to touch
about it, right? Which is again totally
normal. In every server, uh if some if
Hassan says something stupid, it pops up
in your server and people again normal.
>> So I I just don't think this is
>> normal for this space. I want to amend.
>> Yeah.
So, so, so for instance, like I I you
know, I'll reference my drawing again.
Uh, hate watching Twitch poll endlessly.
PII/GOB
saw Twitter like skitso Discord
community sners and skitso DG. Uh, this
is kind of weird. Oh my god. Let people
enjoy things. Uh, uh, this
Well, that that picture helped. Now I
get it. Thank you, Connor. Now I get it.
>> So, what I'm agreeing to is I don't
think this is normal for normal people.
I think this is normal quote unquote for
our space. But I want to I want to drag
you back to a statement about Dan
Saltman. Can I real quick?
>> Yeah.
>> So you said Dan created a specific
Hassan hate discord and did PII gay ops
against Hassan is trying to ruin his
career with his advertisers with Twitch,
etc., etc.
>> Oh, this server thing I'm talking about.
I know there's another Discord server,
but that was like where they were like
posting his family. Let's just say Dan
Salman's gone out of his way to with
Assan's career. Is that accurate enough?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, what Dan said, which I think
is going to he would fall back to
argumentatively and I would potentially
be sympathetic to is that Hassan
deserves it, right? Sweep for Hezbollah,
swept for Hamas, always does apologia
for jihadist organizations and
theocratic regimes worldwide. Hates the
American Empire. What's America to fall
apart? uh m uh
okay it's literally everybody's argument
he analogizes Zionism to Nazism and then
he's also said in the past that Nazis
deser they shouldn't even be or Zionists
shouldn't even be employed as your local
dog walker they or dog catcher they
should actually be like socially
ostracized and banned from humanity so
Dan can say hey um I am going out on my
way to with this guy's social media
career, but I don't think I've ever
Well, at least not recently. I don't
think I've ever heard Dan say he's not
doing it
>> right. He just says that he's doing it
and then he does it.
>> Yeah. That's why
>> this isn't a pass or even a positive
thing. It's like a totally neutral
element.
It's not It doesn't make you better that
you say you do the thing you're doing.
Doesn't make you better. I'm sorry. It
doesn't.
>> I brought it up. What I'm telling you is
that when I think of obsessively trying
to somebody's career, that's what I
think of, right? I've never seen
anything in that server or in JO server
that comes even close to what Dan was
doing there openly on Destiny's main
Discord server and in like the side
servers that he had. No, nowhere even
close. Right. So, I agree that Dan would
say, "Yeah, I'm just doing because Focus
is on." I agree. I I kind of respect
that actually. But, uh, what I'm telling
you is that I I've never seen anything
even close to that. And and if that's
acceptable, I don't think it is. If
that's acceptable to you people, then I
don't understand why you'd have an issue
with what was happening in the server or
in JSON server or in any of these other
server. Now, to be clear, again, I don't
know everything that was happening
there. So, it could be that there there
was like some secret doxing channel that
I just didn't see or or they had like a
big conversation about doxing somebody
that I I just didn't see. Totally
possible, right? I don't know everything
happens in the Discord server, but I
just have not seen any of it. I've never
seen anybody supporting it. I just
haven't. So,
>> okay then I will uh join watch for 3
minutes. E watch for 3 minutes. What is
this? They'll be on multiple accounts.
You saw the phrase gay ops, you know. Um
and that I don't like to say what it is.
You should just ask them and then we'll
see in a month where they still stand,
right? Do you support creating
astroturfed accounts to go into
counterpoint stream? They do that. To go
into pisco stream, they do that. To go
into touch stream, they do that. to
either pretend to be innocent third
parties. They do that. Or to pretend to
be unhinched DJs. They do that when
you're
>> That's evidenced by the logs, right?
>> Yes. And then on that and then on top of
that, when you have them mass reporting
channels,
>> the thing is I would generally
discourage like making accounts to
pretend to be other people. But I don't
see that as like this huge crime, you
know? Like I I I would discourage that.
I don't want people doing that. It looks
stupid. It makes you look mad.
But like is that what what is the uh
what's the what's the criticism there
really? I I don't really understand. But
yeah, some chatters do like that.
>> I mean, I've I've definitely laughed at
the idea of Kathy doing it, but it's
mostly because when Kathy does it, he
like
>> like the idea Sorry, I will just laugh
at this because it was funny to me.
>> Like the idea of Stardust engaging with
Kathy as one of the three chatters that
are in her chat, and she probably knows
that Gunbox is like not a real fan of
hers.
She probably has a good idea, right? But
it's like Kathy is just like talking to
Stardust and Stardust is like engaging
back because it's the only chatter there
like that. I'm sorry that's funny. And
maybe you'd say that's encouraging to
say it's funny, but
I don't know. Like I I guess I like I
discourage it. I would discourage doing
like what I would refer to as like a
chatter gay op. Like if you're going to
go and say I'm a DJer and I think this I
think that's stupid. I don't I don't
want people doing that.
>> Yeah. But but would you like is that
something you're supposed to moderate
around? I if I saying something you're
supposed to moderate I don't why am I
supposed to moderate that? Why am I
supposed to give a someone's doing that
really?
>> The other thing is is like Kathy does it
to us.
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's also it's like sort of a funny
thing that we all know he does. He's
like a character. I don't know. Like I
>> his first couple months of showing up,
it was like, you know, people people
would get one guy by Cathy and then drag
drag whoever it was in and then it'd
come in and be doing an Indian accent.
You'd look stupid and it's like, oh my
god.
>> The one where he calls into peace go
straight and he's like, is it him in
traffic?
>> I'm outside. I'm outside.
>> It's so funny, man. Uh it's like it's
like a whole bit. I don't know.
whatever. Yeah. I don't know if you
moderate around it or whatever. It's I'd
say if you found examples of him doing
like really negative, but it's mostly
like from what I've seen, it's mostly
>> I don't you know I banned Kathy because
of this stupid lone tweet he made cuz
it's just like annoying when I'm trying
to talk to someone. But it's not because
I don't think I should moderate off
platform behavior like ever. I don't
think I've ever got an obligation to do
that really.
I I moderate my communities. That's
That's just my job, right? I I thought,
is that really that crazy?
>> I mean, in this case, I don't know
exactly what Kathy would say. Like, if
Kathy's pushing his own screenshots into
Snark Left and we're all like laughing
at it, then that is involving that
community. You know what I mean?
>> But it's not my Discord. I don't I'm not
a mod there. It's not It's my
responsibility. Like, like I said, if I
had a good idea that the Hutch thing was
Kathy or someone else from that Discord,
I would want them gone. I not even like
probably on on moral grounds, but I
wouldn't make that argument in that
Discord because I don't think most
people like think that way. Like I I
would make it just like this.
>> I feel like you just make a rod for your
own back saying that like I don't I just
don't give a to moderate what every
crazy chatter is saying in every other
chat. I don't I just don't care.
Uh, I I would say like I dislike it.
That's just But it's again a personal
preference. Like it feels like a
liability. That would be what I'd say.
But again, I I don't control that
Discord and I might have a say like I
might have a voice there, but that would
just be my argument and then I would let
other people decide. There's lots of
times I've wanted to ban people from
>> It's your argument and the natural, you
know, sort of like authority that comes
with being a a bigger streamer in an
area with either small streamers or
chatters. It's like but it's like that
you can't be expected to go around
throwing your weight around to get
changed in every Discord server you're
in. Like that's
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. It's like hey
if you are running the server, someone's
running the server and you it's like
I'll give you my argument why I think
this right and then you can make your
decision.
I'll I'll participate and not try to
like put too much influence into it how
I feel about it. Anyway anyway back to
the content. uh when you have them uh a
logging or doxing people in a way that
you can reach out and find other people
in their lives to communicate with. They
do that, right? The worst of that
holding
or doxing people so you can find other
people in their lives to communicate
with. They do that.
That's a that's a lot further than what
I thought. Oh, he's talking about Cyba.
Well, yeah. I to be fair, he like lied
about Cyba being in there. Cyba's never
been in there.
Never seen cyber in there, but I didn't
check it for 3 months. So,
>> yeah. Yeah.
>> Let me uh let me just ask you a question
because obviously this is the kind of
evidence that I would like by the way.
Uh not that it's not available. I just
haven't had
>> Yeah. He Well, he wants to Missy, what
that is right there is that's him trying
to join the idea of my Discord and and
the Snarkle left discord as the same
group of people or the same Yeah. Right.
He wants those tied together because
then he can have some reason to blame my
discord and my community while this
discord could have like could have
potentially been something engaging in
worse behavior which I don't think
they've got any evidence of that at all.
Right. I think he's trying to do the
like you know queen was saying the two
years it was all to tie this together as
one narrative but I think they sort of
overestimated what they had and peace
goes well
certainly was he was on that for a
little bit. Okay, back to the DB combo.
>> The the chorus of people,
>> Assassan Putin and John Fabro are
involved, too. And Kyle Kolinsky. Don't
forget Kyle.
>> You know, Destiny obviously writes his
manifestos at his own pace andor has
co-writers that write them at
>> You don't need it.
>> You don't need the manifesto. You just
need
>> Well, no. That's what I'm saying. I want
I want all I want all the logs.
>> They They made They made a plan today to
post it. should be sorry. Folks right
now should be pressuring Hutch to prove
that Ogre is a full and that actually
boy
>> the
defend defend my lady's honor.
>> Let let me defend Hutch's honor real
quick.
>> You you just you just trust him
implicitly for some reason when he
>> Yeah. He has a You got You guys see a
bald head in a in a blank
>> SSRI stare.
>> Oh my god. And I see a beautiful bald
head
>> and I see a beautiful, you know,
>> detached chair.
>> And so, yeah, I trust him.
>> Conor,
>> let's go.
>> So, but hold on. Hold on with Hutch. I
think that it has been claimed that
there is evidence that this server
participated in the spamming of his dead
sister. Uh, so that's one of the things
that I would want to uh pressure Destiny
and um Hutch to release is one release
all the logs because we should be able
to evaluate the evidence by ourselves,
but then two uh there's been a specific
claim that this server was responsible
for the dead sister gay op. Uh, you
either need to resend that claim or you
need to evidence.
>> It's not a gay up spammy chation.
>> Detent.
>> It's not evening if people don't tell
you tell someone to do it. It's like
some spamming. That's all it is.
>> Yeah. Like I wouldn't say like if if
basically somebody decided to do that
and it eventually gets tied back to
somebody from the server. Like if we had
no way of knowing it if people cuz I
know people asked. People were like,
"Hey, I don't want I want to be a part
of like that." Like, "Fuck off." People
didn't like it and people asked and a
bunch of people went, "No, no, no, no,
no. Absolutely not."
>> So,
>> your folks right now should be to
pressure him to do cuz right now um
>> Oh, I that all that to say is if it's
some acting on their own, it's not about
the character of the server.
>> J,
>> especially when it's like pretty
verifiably outside the character of the
server. Not that people wouldn't joke in
the server. I'm saying it's just it's a
little weird to go to like spam chats.
And as much as as much as Kathy Kathy's
like a a skits or whatever and people
will like say he makes accounts and he
goes to other I haven't seen him like go
and just spam like the most offensive
like he's normally trying to do
something
>> like it's sort of outside of the
behavior and that is not outside of the
behavior of other like YouTube skits
chatters that I've seen in different
communities.
It's like sort of outside of the Kathy
behavior though. It's just and not
saying it couldn't be or something but I
I just haven't seen it from him.
So anyway,
>> yeah, and I would say your folks right
now should be to pressure him to do
because right now um Jay Sulkman,
they're all on Ogrebo's side because Og
Boy has these screenshots, right? Where
we can prove like just outright that he
did say what he what Hutch said he
didn't say. So we So unless Hutch has
any evidence, Hutch is lying. But but
I'm not going to go so far as to say
that it's lying because the the color
the color of
>> Hutch is lying or he is like a emotional
who is making an accusation that's going
to be used to essentially again create a
permission structure manufactured
consent for some negative actions and it
needs to be evaluated now before the bad
things happen.
I had somebody in my chat earlier
tonight saying they were calling the
cops on me. Otter, if you could try to
pressure people into presenting some
evidence for the that's being said, I
would appreciate it. Okay, time is
running out.
>> Time is running out.
>> The ogre boy. So maybe I need to watch
the ogre boy.
>> Can Can I just get Can I get a
commitment from Connor that when my
obituary is published that he'll
eventually go, "Hey, I need that
evidence now." Maybe then at least
Connor,
>> thank you. Thank you. Oh, the thing is
that Destiny's perspective is that he he
was helping Swam. So,
I I say over your lowering coffin
>> without Hutch's coloring of his
statement. Maybe that would be the the
most objective way to do it.
>> But the but the ogre boy, it sounds like
ogre boy.
>> Oh, at the end of the clip I sent, Dusty
shows him some supposed evidence off
screen. I'm going to say that that's me
basically saying here's how you report
Destiny for doxing. That's probably like
the thing. I'd say that's probably the
again I that's me doing that. Okay. So,
>> like I said, I think that must be it
can't be that anything that bad because
um like I spoke to Connor. He said, "I
haven't seen anything that couldn't be
resolved by calling you the fa about
both of us."
>> Is that I'm just telling you how it
sounds. It sounds like Ogre Boy is at
the gym. He sees somebody spamming
Hutch's dead sister in the chat. He
goes, "Oh, everybody's blaming me." He
DMs Pisco and he says, "Hey, bro. Just
let you know that's not me." He goes to
the Discord and he says, "Hey, is
anybody doing this? I'm getting blamed
for it." That's not a like impugning of
anybody doing it. That that that's not
even a negative statement. Like like
he's not calling it. He's literally
doublecheing.
So this is why I said that you need to
watch the statement again because when
Ogre boy says that he went to the
discord server and asked if if they were
doing this or said it's not you guys
doing this is it Hutch said that that
was a lie. So he so not even oh he ogre
was claiming he came in and yelled at
people and Hutch was saying that is a
lie. He's saying that Ogreway didn't
even go in and ask if it was them doing
it right. So so that
>> fantastic stuff Connor.
>> Yes I would encourage you to watch it
again. He decided to go on your
>> How How did you even do this?
>> I'm muted right now and uh over my
>> chat, so I need to unmute. Um I would
need to see that specific clip of him
saying like no, Ogre Boy never went into
the server in order to challenge people.
And I don't think it would be never went
into the server. I think the the the
object in question would be too
>> I what I want to know is why is the
screenshot they're presenting there why
is that cropped without the time stamp?
You know what I mean? Like that's the
screenshot Hutch is presenting there is
cropped without the the time stamp. That
feels incredibly intentional to me,
doesn't it? It just feels so bizarre
that they're going to crop that without
the time stamp and say look look at
this. Look at this terrible terrible
thing. I do agree that it would be like
a lone actor because there just broadly
isn't consensus to go after like
somebody publicly for that kind of thing
to like attack them in that way. You
know what I mean? So, I do think it
seems like a lone agent, but I'd still
like to know who it was so be like,
"Hey,
>> what are you doing?"
>> Uh, the original link it
someone was spamming Hutch killed his
sister over and over again and people
were blaming me. Two dead reactions.
That's a very neutral statement. And
then that's not you guys spamming live
and learn, is it? Once again, that's
like a neutral statement. He's not he's
not saying that. And and by the way, by
the way, Ogre Boy said that he said that
better not be any of you. So, is Ogre
boy hyperbolizing his pos?
>> Yes, those are the logs he's presenting
position in order to look better
optically or is
>> probably not remembering precisely what
he said.
>> Is he um exaggerating? Well, hold on.
No, no, no. That's exactly what he's
doing. I don't even know why I'm
pretending to entertain this.
>> He probably felt that way and then he
came into a space that he was like not
had not been in for that long, right?
And he probably didn't know how to be
like that aggressive and so he's
probably feeling that way. There better
not be any of you guys.
>> Also, it's like, you know, what you're
supposed to he doesn't know that it's
anyone in there doing it and he's
supposed to watch Spur out the moment it
happens. Assume it's someone in there.
>> Exactly.
>> Like this is obviously an equivalent
statement, right? Hey, this isn't you
guys, right? This isn't you guys, right?
It's like they're the same thing. I
don't know. To call him a liar over this
is itself a lie in my opinion. Say
you're a liar cuz you
>> cuz you slightly hyperbolize this.
>> He's exaggerating the way that he called
out the server in order to look like he
doesn't want anything to do with these
gay ops.
>> No,
>> but that's not what he said. There
there's no moral indignation in these
two screenshots.
I think it's a misreading. So Urggo
isn't saying, my understanding is that
he went in there and yelled at them.
What he's saying is that if it was them,
he would go in there and yell at them
because he thinks it's up and even if
he's new there, he he still thinks it's
wrong, so he would go in there and yell
at them. And he's saying that he he's so
outraged by that behavior that he was
being accused of that if it were them,
he'd be angry, right? And he he yell at
them. So this and uh and uh what um
Hutch is saying is that he never even
asked in the server if it if it was
them. So
>> okay then then then I I would have to
>> we should just pressure Hush today to
release the screenshots he claims he has
that will show the people posting about
his death sister at that time with Ogre
boy there aware that it's happening and
like because otherwise Hutch is just
just lying. Okay, I buy into
>> I buy into in order to for me to claim
that somebody is a liar. Maybe I have a
higher threshold. I can't this could to
me a misunderstanding of the statement.
So for instance,
>> the misunderstanding can be cleared up
by one of the parties.
Should be pushing for the
misunderstanding to be cleared up.
that Ogre Boy saying
um and they were banned cuz somebody's
spamming that in my chat right now.
JTO's contention is saying that Ogre Boy
didn't mean that the people who were
harassing uh Hutch and Libid Learns chat
were banned from the Starker
Discord.
>> Oh no. My contention is that anybody
who' said that Hutch's made a joke about
Hutch's dead sister in that server
wouldn't be banned for it. That's my
contention. He was saying that they were
pretty close to instantaneously banned
from the Lib and Learn chat, but based
off of the words,
>> I could understand how Hutch would infer
that he said that they were banned from
the server. So, that to me isn't Hutch
going like, "Oh, yeah. Uh, I'm I don't
have any evidence for these claims, but
I'm going to claim that I have the
evidence for the claims, and I'm going
to exaggerate the situation so people
are are uh sympathetic to me." That to
me literally could be explained by a
misunderstanding of the words happening.
So for me to call Hutch a liar, I would
>> fine. So
if you want to hold off on calling him a
liar right now and maybe I just don't I
don't trust Hutch implicitly the way
that you do.
>> Yeah, his SSRI stand bald head rub you
wrong. I got it.
>> Um what I would just encourage everybody
to do is tell Hush to just post the logs
that he has about this specific
interaction with the people there that
were that were doing it. That can happen
today. Has nothing to do with the
manifesto. So there's no reason to wait.
And that would prove immediately that
that ogre boy is lying and nobody should
trust him. That that JTO is lying and
nobody should trust him because JCO, if
I remember correctly, he also said that
he looked at the logs, right? And it
wasn't there. So that would prove
immediately that it's all a lie. They're
all they're all full of how could you do
that right now and it just imploded.
>> Um I said I couldn't see that in the
logs, but I don't know like when that
was deleted, if that was deleted. I what
I was talking about with the logs was I
could see that multiple people were
saying no no no that's not us that's not
us that's not us nobody took nobody took
responsibility for it nothing like that
>> yeah so
>> but I but I think Ogre boy made a uh as
much as I dislike the guy I find him to
truly be one of the least pleasant
people on the internet uh I think he did
make a good point the reason why they're
not releasing all the logs right now uh
this is I'm trying to quote him almost
directly is he's saying like they could
release all the logs call everybody in
the server gay and move on. But they
want to drip feed this in order to
maximize the content and the drama so
they can villainize everybody who's in
the server without actually evidencing
their claims or criticisms. And I think
that's just true. Um I I think they are
I think they are milking it.
>> Yeah, I agree. I think they're they're
uh building this narrative so they can
lie uh hyperboise, exaggerate, and and
people will just believe it because it
sounds right to them. Yeah, but I told I
told Queen this the other day.
>> Sorry. Go ahead.
>> Mr. White Hut should be encouraged not
to post all the logs but the logs about
this specific interaction that he
>> all cop redemption arc. No, no. I feel
like Connor is about to make the point
that like actually if you have nothing
to hide, you have nothing to fear. So
you should just publish everything. It's
like how about the people making the
allegation? The way every other system
works in the entire world, the people
making the allegation post the actually
alleging. How about that? claims Ogre
Boy is lying about.
>> If he has this, he can prove that Ogre
is full of right now and just destroy
his reputation. Destroy Jay Sock's
reputation right now. There's no reason
to wait for anything else. He doesn't
need to release all the logs. Just this
specific thing.
>> Yeah, that's all he needs to do.
>> But he he he doesn't want to up Destiny
sweating the
>> So instead of getting the truth, instead
of like not letting this Paul the
hangover, you just want to let Desi run
his stupid. Okay. also like sweating the
snarkers. Like this is energized people.
People are active. People are
interested, engaged. So you can say
people sweat. I'm sure some people are
panicking at some point. They don't
don't know what they've said. They can't
check their logs or but I mean I feel
like everything's chill at least for
most content creators
>> for us. Yeah.
>> Next two months and then releasing a
manifesto that gets 20,000 live, you
know.
>> Yeah. Yeah, but you you know that's a
stupid that's a stupid position. So him
>> it's a stupid position politically and
interpersonally
>> you're just Connor just wants him to win
which is unfortunate but like do you
know what I mean? Like that's the only
thing. It's just prioritizing destiny
winning with impact on his manifesto in
two months or however many months we're
waiting for his court case. In the
meantime I've got people spamming PII
for people in my community in Hutch's
chat. I've got people in my chat saying
they're calling the cops. Okay. I would
I would like some resolution on some of
these things, Connor, because I feel
like things are getting really heated.
>> But hey, I'll
>> Connor does say that Destiny's going
scorched earth and is not shown the
evidence to justify it.
>> He does say that.
>> Okay.
>> So, I mean, he does say it's wrong. He
does say it's wrong.
>> Well, there's some coralaries of that.
It's like people should not be
politically tied to this person. this
person is a like duplicitous
I don't know borderline evil person
who's only self-interested like some
other consequences of this that you
should admit you know what I mean
>> I think Connor sees it as just like he's
just like you know it's a transactional
thing where he's using Destiny and
Destiny uses him you know
>> okay question about that
>> that's my my vibe from Connor basically
sees as transactional and that you know
it's a it's a he'll continue associating
with Destiny cuz he thinks that's good
Yeah,
>> that's useful to him.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I have crazy hate for that. I'm not
like crazy upset about that.
>> Moral cleansing. Well, I just I don't
want these people to ever act like
they're like acting based on morals
here.
>> It's a smart position if you want money
>> in general. No, it's not. It's okay.
>> Don't you love money, Doobie? I for one
know that you love money.
>> It's It doesn't make any sense, Connor.
So for Hutch, it would make more sense
to pull some of that engagement away
right now because it exists and pull it
to his stream for the exposure stream
where he shows that Ogre Boy is full of
and JC was lying and didn't blow the
entire thing himself. There's no reason
for him to give that to Destiny. So he
could do that right now. He just post
the the Ogre by interaction.
>> It'd be very simple. He'd make money
doing it. DJ would come to support him.
Be all very like have he'd get a victory
over over the Snarkers. It'd be very
good for him. Mhm.
>> There's no reason not to do that right
now.
>> Did you see DJ's doing a call to action
to call the Canadian CIA on you? CSIS,
not even your FBI equivalent. Uh, no,
but I mean, people were coming in my
chat and doing it. So, I assume
something like that was happening.
>> Kind of crazy, but what can you do?
>> But but and I want to say really
quickly, um,
>> by what can you do? I mean,
>> I don't know, dude. Skittles is going to
be skits, man.
>> Sort of. So people in chat have been
saying that I justified um a logging uh
Destiny's son which is ridiculous. Um so
and I think one of them said that I just
like the standard the difference in
standards here like Dub saying you
completely destroy the reputation. It's
like okay if you show these guys lying
one time they'll completely you'll
completely destroy the reputation. Now
let's get to lie 9,000. Provable lie
9,000 from Destiny and we'll analyze
that. Like that's that's the thing is
Trump. Connor says he doesn't like
Trump. Connor says he moves over to the
center, maybe even center left and
canvases with Democrats because he hates
Trump. And his favorite guy on earth is
just liberal Trump.
It makes no [__] Like it's so that's my
problem with Connor is he just obviously
doesn't hold any of the standards or
morals he claims to have. It's very
frustrating to listen to.
It's not It's not that he just is using
somebody. It's that he pretends he is
somebody. He pretends he's a certain guy
with certain morals and he's not. Even
not even close. It's very frustrating to
me to let that go. Just shut up about
being a good person. Shut up about
caring about things. Just say you're
here to make money. Like me. I say I'm
here to make money. Don't pretend you
care about morals. Don't care about any
of that. Don't pretend you care about
this when it's obvious you go back on
everything you say all the time.
>> That I did um a log Destiny Center that
I do do that to like go after his
employers when he's like awake like a an
adult. Um, so total total nonsense to be
clear. I don't agree with that. I don't
think it's justified. I didn't do it.
There's a guy on Twitter that W's
speaking to. I think it was like a month
uh like a little over a month ago. Um
who said that he was going to a
Destiny's son and then when he gets like
all the crazy that Destiny's been saying
on Twitter like the old right stuff.
>> Um he's going to track it all and then
when he gets old enough to get a job
he's going to send it to his employer to
like him. I I think that's wrong. I
don't think anybody should ever do this.
And what I said to Wick because Wick had
the guy on and they were talking about
it, right? What I said to Wick is that
uh if Destiny wants to build this tit
fortat um world where you can do where
he can put people's families at risk um
then there's no reason that they can't
put his family at risk. So if that's
what he wants to do, he's creating the
permission structure to justify that. I
don't think any of us should. I don't
think he should do that. I don't think
they should do that. Nobody should do
that. But that's what he's been doing to
other people for like over a year now.
So I have a family. I have a wife. I
have a son. I have 764 people. Adam
Waffen people people 098 people been
trying to find years that made very
violent threats at me for years that
I've gotten arrested repeatedly for
years. And he's he's trying to dox me.
He's encouraging people to dox me. That
puts my family at risk.
>> So I think I'd be totally justified in
with him in very severe ways actually
that that are go far beyond legal. But
I'm not going to do that because I don't
like that world. Right. So if you know
and I'm I'm on the sidelines what people
do with that back to him.
>> I'm on the sidelines and everybody hates
this because it's too boring. But uh I
think some of y'all need Jesus. And what
I mean by that is like
>> this is what I'm talking about. Quan,
I'm sorry. It's like so
literally just understand the scripture
of like turning the other cheek.
Somebody hits you. Somebody hits you in
the face, you turn the other cheek. Um,
and then somebody asks you for your
cloak, you give them your jacket, too.
Somebody asks you to walk one mile with
them, you walk two miles with them. And
so the the whole point of that attitude
is to actually I just heard all I'm
asking is if you're going to say this,
stop sucking Satan's. Okay, that's all
that's literally it. That's like the
only bar I have. Don't
>> don't pretend you care about this stuff.
Don't you have morals? And then say like
this and then just be like, but also I'm
going to wait for Destiny. I'm going to
wait until it's 2 years since Destiny
started saying you're a doctor. Then
I'll then I'll ask them for some
evidence. Then I'll get some evidence.
Then I'll actually make a stand on this.
>> This recently is when somebody hits you
in the face, they're demeaning you,
right? When they hit you again and you
don't have a response, you're
effectively accepting the fact that or
you're you're saying, "No, I'm on your
level. Probably I'm better than you
because your hit doesn't even do
anything to me."
>> So So that's the that's kind of the
point of turning the other cheek. Now, I
do understand that there comes a time
where especially like, you know, cuz
we're not Christ. Um, there's a time
where it's like you can't just take hits
to the face anymore. You have to do
something. Uh, but I do think that DGG,
and I've criticized them, and I think
you've heard me criticize them in this,
they say they're doing tit fortat, but
they're doing barbarian retributive
violence. So they see that Morau and not
Morau, excuse me. They see that uh Shimu
and Nicandros are engaged in PII gay ops
on a server and they're saying, "Oh,
okay. Well, they've engaged in doxing.
We don't care about the context of it.
So, we're going to just rape everyone
like like because Queean and Jtock hate
on the DGG community and hate on Destiny
so much. We're going to use this as a
war pretext to Jtock
Quean
Doobie and anybody who's critic uh
criticizing us and that's effectively
barbarian retributive violence. And I
think that's descriptively true. Like do
you do you think that um and I know
you're going to say no to this, but I'm
asking your chat really um like do they
think it would be reasonable or
justified for Hassan to uh to dox all of
them to encourage this community to find
every single one of them with their
families because that is what they are
doing. They they should talk Asan
constantly. They criticize him whenever
he does dumb. This is earlier today. um
whenever you guys stream about Hassan,
people in chat saying he's a monster,
evil communist or whatever the So if and
openly trying to ruin this guy's career,
encouraging people to get him like a to
report him, get him off Twitch, get him
off YouTube, whatever. So like if that
justifies uh doxing people and trying to
like uh find their family and with them,
then all of them have justified they've
just justified doing that to themselves.
Yeah. If I were to just said in chat
that uh DGG is justified in everything,
destiny means no rules. Well, found
runner, you have a wife and kids. What
you're justifying there is me or
somebody else finding your family and
with your children. I don't think you
actually want to live in that world. I I
get this quote to be as you on the
internet and say dumbit like that. That
is not okay. So So I I just I'm
encouraging you just take a step back,
just think about what you're saying and
what you're encouraging and what you're
like condoning uh to be done to you even
if you don't give a [__] if it's done to
other people.
>> No, no, no. And and I think that u I
know a lot of people are critical of you
in chat or whatever, but I think that if
they were to take anything away, let's
take a step back. Let's think about the
world that we're creating. Let's think
about the behaviors that we're endorsing
and let's uh come up with like rules of
the game that doesn't result in
everybody getting raped.
>> Thanks for talking. Well, thanks for
coming on and uh I you know, as much as
we beef about Israel Palestine
sometimes, I I hope that you don't get
digitally.
>> Yeah, you're so wrong about everything
and your world view makes a world worse.
Okay, [__] you. But I love you. Bye-bye.
>> Okay. I love you, too. Bye.
>> Oh, should point out that Desi's like a
disingenuous liar. Like I I That's what
I think he doesn't do. He's like, you
shouldn't like Desessie lies about
everything all the time. Yes, Desi's a
consistent liar. That's that's just
shown that Desty's a consistent liar.
And I think not saying that it feels
like you don't have to cut him off, but
you should be able to accurately like
this is your standard as well, Queen. If
he he's not saying Dan's a doxer, he's
not like ribbing Dan for doxing. He is
he is quite literally like not saying
the thing, which is Desi is a liar. He's
a totally unreliable narrator. You
shouldn't trust anything he says. Which
I think is just objectively true at this
point.
And it's rough.
And Destiny could change that opinion by
showing Connor the the evidence he has
for the claims he's made, but it just
isn't happening. It's never happening.
Okay. All right. Okay. All right.
See here. We got anything funny at the
end of this combo going on here. Uh, by
the way, I'm pretty sure Hutch is I I
feel like I'm pretty confident Hutch is
a liar. Like total liar. Obvious liar.
Five.